[Music]
we're getting our first look at a
remarkable piece of middle eastern
history in addition to the dead sea
scrolls
fragments of biblical script and other
writings were found recently in a cave
by israeli archaeologists
they're believed to have been there
since the early days of christianity mts
taeyab reports
on the material and amazing story it
tells
good morning well when the dead sea
scrolls were first found over
70 years ago it was widely considered to
be one of the most
important archaeological discoveries of
the 20th century
the biblical text nearly 2 000 years old
gave us a rare insight into the history
of judaism
early christianity and humankind
with these new findings shining an even
brighter light
onto our past it's called the cave
of horror and it's easy to see why given
the only way
for archaeologists to access it is by
rappelling down the side
of a sheer cliff although the history of
the cave is as dark as its name implies
excavators describe what they found
inside as between
heaven and earth wow
dozens of fragments pieces of the dead
sea scrolls
uncovered after nearly two millennia the
scroll fragments are small
some minuscule but big enough to still
draw wisdom from
says dr orrin abelman who reads one of
the uncovered passages
these are the things you are to do speak
the truth to one another
render true and perfect justice in your
gates and do not
contrive evil against one another the
arid conditions of the judean desert has
ensured dozens of other objects have
also withstood the test of time
including these ancient
or not remnants of clothing and sandals
as well as a wooden lice comb
similar to one that might be used today
archaeologist kaim cohen says the
four-year project is vital to protect
the treasures
within the caves from future plunder
this project
is the protection of the area because
again it is almost impossible to beat
the looters to
uh find the looters while they're
working and the
the solution was to get to the case
before the looters
the massive excavation site spans parts
of southern israel
and the occupied west bank but israel
has long been criticized for removing
objects found in palestinian areas
according to international law taking
cultural property from an occupied
territory
is forbidden and yet those concerns
haven't prevented the israeli
antiquities authority
from putting the discoveries on display
in jerusalem
some of the discoveries go well beyond
the biblical like this 6
000 year old skeleton of a small child
and this
almost perfectly preserved basket which
wouldn't look out of place at a home
furnishing store today
the cave is empty we found everything
and then when we came
we understood that we we're looking at a
whole
intact basket we took it and send it
to weitzman institution to carbon dated
and when the results came back we were
shocked
it is 10 thousand and five
hundred years old a dazzling puzzle
piece
from the past found alongside ancient
wisdoms
which still resonate today for cbs this
morning
in fiasco london this incredible window
into the past
they got me with the best one yeah